now I'm feeling about hands and I'm
really looking forward to this we've got
two very dynamic people who will be
taking the lead on this as I introduce
you please come up and take your seat on
stage and we'll take it away I'm
delighted that also traveling with this
from Pittsburgh is cotton Srinivasan
cotton is the first row het tolani
distinguished professor international
business that's as in row head tolani
our alumnus and co-host who gave the
money to make this chair possible not
that chair but you know that sure Conan
is an expert in marketing and management
science premium highly sophisticated
analytical and quantitative methods to
marketing he's particularly well known
for working at the intersection of
marketing and operations lately he's
been very active in internet marketing
and with terror focus on auction related
companies ladies gentlemen professor
Srinivasan
we're very informal ago you can have a
seat our other panelists is Sam sin Sam
is senior executive vice president head
of the global corporate bank of overseas
Chinese banking corporation or better
known as ocbc Sam's also the parents of
a sophomore in humanities and Social
Sciences which is how it got to know him
and why we get him to Pittsburgh from
time to time in his role as senior EVP
Sam is head of all global corporate and
commercial customer relationships and
handles all corporate clients here in
Singapore and Malaysia and in many other
overseas branches Sam also serves as
director of Singapore Island bank
limited ocbc bank China limited in as
president commissioner of PT bank ocbc
in Indonesia I'm very glad that Sam
agreed to be with us today and we found
him here in Singapore Sam Sam Sam
alright so we're going to start by my
asking our panelists some individual
questions and get them talking I'll do
this for a few minutes and then pretty
quickly turn it over to you so please be
thinking about the questions you'd like
to ask cotton or for Sam and kind of
let's start with you as we all know
we've heard a lot about and probably Tom
Friedman popularized it more than
anybody the new global economy are not
so new anymore global economy is very
much a product of new technology and is
particularly information communication
technologies made possible by that and
as I mentioned in my introduction of you
marketing and an Internet is something
you can react it in so one of the
questions that occurs in that sort of
sphere is what kind of problems do you
see for internet marketers especially
working between countries where so much
it is global anyhow and what trends do
you see in them all right let me kind of
tell you a little bit of work some of
the research work I do this area so that
you know you know that I'm coming from
as you can imagine the internet
generates enormous murder data and one
of the things that I've been working on
is how do you leverage data to make
sense out of this one of the very early
things that I did almost it's about
seven or eight years ago which is
basically to look at if consumers are
clicking on actual data can we say
something you know one of the big
challenges most companies faces people
actually serve most of the time and eggs
it right and not everybody buys it's
very different than the regular retail
environment if you're going to car for a
Walmart eighty percent of the people
don't come in and not buy anything they
end up buying something so one of the
very early models that we worked on was
can I look at the pattern of data and
which are clicking from
that can i assign dynamic probabilities
turns out to be a little bit of an
advanced methodology called hidden
Markov models but the basic thing that
we were able to predict out of that was
if I see sixth of your clicks we will be
able to predict with a very high
probability ninety percent accuracy
whether you want to surf the web and
exhibit or whether you're going to
actually buy so that's an interesting
thing wait we actually did it with
barnes noble amazon was really interest
rate some point at some point in time
because how do we convert some of those
people who come in to surf the web and
convert them into actual bias now an
interesting story and this is you slowly
at some point in time you don't think
when you are clicking through this
somebody can tell you this so it's also
some very interesting privacy issues a
second set of research work we did with
one of my colleagues is that actually we
can profile you by looking at the set of
sites that you've been visiting we can
figure out what your ages which your
income is what your generous education
level and that makes some people very
uncomfortable so you know we do this
with the it's a 2h to swerve at one
level as researchers we tell you what
the power of what the data can tell you
we also to another level we are also
kind of exposing you to say that you
might be thinking when somebody says ask
this information I'm not providing this
information it's no longer necessary we
can kind of track what you're doing and
we can start profiling you so an
interesting area where I think when I
when I kind of look at the international
issues the notion of what we think about
privacy differs across countries right I
originally come from India codon court
Indians value privacy to a lesser extent
that were Europeans and Americans
depends so that both opens up
opportunity it also closes opportunity
for you and so that's one area where I
see that there is going to be huge
difference across countries in terms of
what they can leverage more technarch
leverage the second thing that I think
that an interesting divergence that's
emerging between various countries is in
the area mobile versus Internet in a
country like india until lesser extent
perhaps in china it is the mobile phone
that will drive the internet usage
mobile phone is still the preferred
medium of communication text messaging
is the most probably famous play two
things in fact actually is the Silicon
Valley funded company aggressively in
India focused on text message based
marketing not internet based marketing
so a lot of thin clients of the mobile
because the mobile market is several
times bigger than the internet market
okay so for those of you who are looking
for opportunities across countries I
think that's a tremendous divergence
between us and India us and china mobile
phone is still a very powerful effective
way of communicating so this company
actually every month sends our three
billion marketing text messages right
and so almost accounts for ten percent
of all the text messages that under the
year those are some of the very
interesting differences that you see
across these countries that's very good
it raises a lot of questions but I'm
going to home by Tommy hope that others
will a somebody's return the same for a
minute and come back to you later here's
a tough question but it sort of has to
be asked in America at least bankers
have come in for a lot of criticism in
the last couple of years being blamed
for the recession in America at least
the thicker focus on overly risky
investments or risky lending practices
etc and one thing that's called foreign
american
new regulations maybe even the
regulatory body your impression sort of
what the global scene is with regard to
banking and risk-taking and whether you
see a global on super regulatory
authority emerging would be interested
and very timely this is a popular
question yeah it's a sensitive question
its controversial I work with a banking
industry but I try to be as unbiased as
possible first of all I think this
recent events that led to the recent
financial crisis the pursuit of risky
loans is pursued in an environment which
is very conducive for these sort of
things to happen one of the things that
we see was there is extreme amount of
liquidity in the market interest rates
was extremely low and one other thing
which is not frequently talked about
which is an observation that we need to
share with you is that there is quite a
bit of concentration of funds in fewer
hands if you look at 20 years ago most
of the people who put their money in a
bank in a savings account in the time
deposit account but over the past 20
years the development of private equity
funds of mutual funds of hedge funds
have resulted in these funds gradually
rotating into fewer hands these
institutions fund managers they try to
pursue for additional incremental profit
because they want to compete with each
other in order to deliver a better
return for their investors and I think
this has contributed to the institutions
trying to find a riskier but more
profitable products for their for the
investors so that is a phenomenon which
I believe contributed to the creation of
exalted products
leveraged products which then created a
compounded problem in a market where the
liquidity is abundant and people has got
the greed to continue to pursue for
these profits so then what is it that we
could do about it president Cohen
mentioned about you know is it a good
thing to have a super regulatory body
two losers coordinate all of the world
efforts I think in the way it's already
being done first of all in getting the
country's out of this financial crisis
all of the central banks of the world
for the first time have worked together
to come up with arrangements and
subsidies and rescues that try to
contain this problem secondly there is
already an institution called Bank of
International Settlement which in the
way is the central bank of central
bank's try to put together new measures
to make sure that the banks and other
financial institutions if they were to
face the similar situations in the
future will not create the sort of a
financial turmoil and they do this in
the fairly traditional way in december
of last year they have announced a
series of measures which they try to
address the capital problem and the
liquidity problem to the market faced
one of them that the measures that they
have introduced is try to make sure that
during the good times the bank needs to
keep more capital during the bad times
the bank will be able to utilize those
capitals accumulated during the good
times to support them during the bad
times they call it pro cyclicality
approaches another measure which they
try to introduce is to redefine what is
called capital of the bank you know as
you know as we as we land money the most
important thing that we can ultimately
rely on is first of all capital and
secondly liquid
so on the capital side currently a lot
of instruments are captured into the
capital such as you know in addition to
what we normally no paid up capital plus
retained earnings you have preferred
shares you've got subordinated debt and
then you've got hybrids now there is a
move try to reduce the components of
capital to fewer instruments maybe only
two paid up capital and retained
earnings all these Perpetual's hybrids
convertibles preferred food no longer be
counted so the quality of the capital is
being is being increased right now the
another measure that is being done is
create some control over how much
expansion to the bank in town as you may
have noted recently in the US the the
president has announced to have Paul
Volcker relook at whether commercial
banks should be able to utilize
depositor money to go into leveraged
transactions which are the areas that
investment banks used to do so they try
to do a lot of these these controls I
think ultimately what these measures
will achieve is it is going to suppress
the activities events for a while and
then after that the pursuit of return
the pursuit of profit is going to return
to the banking industry and it will move
of gradually away from what we were able
to achieve for a short while as a result
of these measures some of these
activities that were engaged by the bank
in pursuit of profit with hindsight we
can say it does not really create
economic value for the society so maybe
going forward we should use that
principal it's difficult to to reduce
that you goes through the principle that
banks should really be allowed to pursue
activities that create
nomming value and then with that
principle we try to work through what
are the rules that we can introduce to
direct the banks towards those
activities we don't know whether it's
successful or not but perhaps following
this principle this sort of events that
we have seen over the past few years
over the past two years would not be
repeated give Sam I want to go back to
the one thing you met you refer to an
organization as the length of its
international sentiment yeah what is
that is that an independent thing or is
a part of an international organization
does it come out of the IMF or no it is
an international organization called the
bank of Internet Bank of International
Settlement and the member of this
organization also all of the central
banks around the world and they do meet
annually to talk about what are the
issues that a financial market our face
and in this crisis they have a task for
specifically formed to see what
improvements can t make particularly in
the area of liquidity and capital so
that this sort of crisis systemic risk
could be reduced interesting I guess
that also says there's probably more
coordination among the banks that we
might have thought yes sir in the course
yes particularly during this crisis it
was not seen as you may know president
goin that during the late 90s too early
two thousand there's this asian
financial crisis right during that time
the court there was some coordination
amongst the Asian thanks but there was
no coordination amongst the global days
so let me let me throw out another topic
regatta dabbling around here and then
we'll pursue some more fully on the
audience turns I ask some questions you
can't talk about a global anything
without talking about Indian China
especially sitting here is
important I'd be interested in your
observations about Indian China
relationship to each other but
especially how Singapore sees itself
relating to India China in the banking
industry or more generally and I know
Singapore as a nation and Singapore
institutions are keenly aware of
Singapore's role in the world and always
reminded how small Singapore is compared
to science especially like China and
India so one question I imagine for
Singapore Singaporean companies
especially is being competitive with the
giants like the banking industry of
Shanghai thanking you vampire whatever
so your thoughts about India China or
the relationship to each other
relationship to Singapore whatever you
like to say and that would be valuable
interesting we'd like to go first
Singapore is sometimes called the red
dot because it is just that little red
dot on the world map so we're very small
Singapore is engaging both China and
India to pursue for business
opportunities and those business
opportunities are both inward bound and
outbound in terms of outbound
Singapore's doing quite a bit of things
to encourage Singapore companies to move
offshore to create activities for the
Singapore companies because the domestic
market here is just so respecting so
small that they are not able to continue
to grow without an external market and
Singapore is therefore encouraging the
companies to go into China same thing
about India but I guess because of the
cultural relationship of the people are
the Singapore companies are are engaging
China more than that of Singapore at
least this is based on my observation of
the client base that we have in
Singapore
on the other hand we are also inviting
companies from China and from India to
come into Singapore to do things such as
fundraising Treasury type of activities
as well as create businesses which are
less labor-intensive such as testing
centers things like that I think these
are the things that that is being done
but on the other hand Singapore is not
only engage in China in India Singapore
can really only survive by serving more
as many countries as possible so the
ASEAN nations is another important
region that Singapore is working on so
suffice it to say that I think the push
for Singapore to move out to create
activities with Singapore companies and
also to attract investments to come in
here to do the activities that thing
about is good at has been very very
strong the Singaporean population is
about was it sixty or seventy percent
Chinese tactic Chinese yeah it's about
yes majority majority of that is Chinese
yes yeah indian is about ten percent
that person sorry card no just wanted to
add a few things to that I think
Singapore is I think making certain very
good decisions number one is focusing on
education this tremendous need for
higher education in this region
particularly countries like India the
demand for higher education my mind is
going to grow exponentially over the
next five to 10 years I mean part of
these and why we should be here and why
we are here I think is a good thing for
us I think that's a very important value
add capital I'm sorry intellectual
capital intensive business that will
serve them very well long term in terms
of financial markets from whatever
little I know I think there's a
significant competition between Shia
Mumbai and Singapore still both China
and India have to go significant ways in
terms of clearing transparencies in
their market where they're getting
better this all the time there is still
a certain mortar reluctance for
international pension funds and so on
and so forth to invest directly in to
venture capital firms into India our
private equity firms into India and I
think if you do that in Singapore
there's a greater degree of Reliance in
the fact that the Singaporeans will do
much stronger due diligence and this is
the stronger notion of corporate
governance that they can leverage and I
think that will be a significant add on
a third area where I think Singapore
could benefit and will be an interesting
way in which for them to contribute
would be Singapore has been closer to
the has a far greater understanding of
the US markets an area where there is a
significant shortage of capital still in
India and China I know some other
private equity firms an idea and I think
it's true of China as well as the
early-stage funding is not very
aggressive in these countries so the
tremendous dearth of capital at the very
early stages and they don't because they
see that is extremely risky and these
countries still haven't really
established themselves as the innovative
centers like a Silicon Valley and so on
and so forth so most of the time you
would see is a significant amount of
funding that's available for late stage
companies not for early-stage companies
and I think Singapore still because of
its understanding these markets could be
a significant player in terms of
early-stage companies and the fourth
level in which I would depend then i
would say here and stop here will be in
terms of slipper is probably singapore
and malaysia for example are the first
in terms of raising the sovereign
capital very significant amounts temasek
and
khazanah in Malaysia and actually if you
benchmark it as the percentage is their
GNP it's very substantial terms of how
they have put their own government
private pension fund a government
pension funds into these sovereign funds
and have really leveraged that and
utilize that right and I think that's a
still a very significant area advantage
was these countries because i still
think India particularly runs the
significant deficit so they don't have
significant dollars to put it to private
equity funds and the last one which I
think particularly looking at India is
that for those of you would be there
recently I think with all the India is
the huge contrast mighty and physical
infrastructure it's a country that is
contributing globally on the IT
infrastructure has a you know really
backward physical infrastructure and
everybody recognizes anywhere upwards of
500 billion two trillion dollars is
required in India and Singapore has done
this very well and is in a position to
add you know really participate in that
phase of Indian economy that will
probably go on to the next 10-15 minutes
one of the points I wish to underscore
is the point that Professor paid that is
about the international knowledge at
Singapore has and this is very very
important this applies not only to
companies but if you look at the
government of Singapore they're very
international they know what's happening
in the world and they wanted to make
sure that the advantages that Singapore
has the legal system the corporate
governance the transparencies that
discipline we will promote it as much so
that we can bring this to an overseas
market and use it as a competitive
advantage and to bring the companies to
invest into Singapore or otherwise use
the Singapore as the funding market for
their overseas activities on the on the
other hand singapore government also
uses its own international knowledge to
invest their reserve
into the international businesses to
continue to create value of the funds
that the country has created so that
international knowledge is very
important and in this context president
oh and when you mentioned about you know
the internationalization of the univ of
CMU it is something that we really need
to promote it is something that
Singapore really has made the best use
of and if we can sort of continue to
work towards that direction with your
university programs introduced I think
it would just reinforce our position
boom I certainly agree with your
observation about how international
Singaporeans we certainly see that in
the higher education sector all in your
three universities are linked to many
many universities and in other countries
is they made a point of doing it yes
from the very beginning very conscious
about that and without question it is
serve the nation very well yes so let me
invite your questions about any topics
we've just sort of touched on a few
things but we've got to excellent
thoughtful people here be happy and
responded in you might have on most ok I
mother
so I sent my father
right but it's a lot of money maybe I'll
take I'll take China I think there are
economic excesses in the country as a
result of this fast growth so there's a
certain element of Miss allocation of
resources however i do not think China
will end up in the hard landing I we
have to recognize the China is still
essentially planned economy the
government has got a lot of mechanisms
built in the system to direct the
resources to appropriate areas and they
have a lot of experience as well the
first cycle that they experienced was in
the 1980s of which they did not handle
very well and after that it was sort of
a hard landing which resulted in a slow
growth for China correction of past
economic sense for about five to six
years but the cycle that happened in the
90s the cycle that happened in the
Indian Indian early 2000 we have handled
it very very well during this time over
the past two years when the global
economy was facing a lot of challenges
the Chinese government directed the
economy to creating domestic demand and
as a result of the surgeon domestic
demand despite the fall in expo
the country continues to be very stable
and continue to grow at a very
respectable rate so i think it is true
that there are economic excesses that
has created and but i believe that the
government of china will be able to
control those successes in such a way
that would not result in an economy
ended up in the heart lending they
started to put the brakes on okay why
everything yes what they did is that in
the early part of last year which is
about which is january of last year they
recognize what's happening in the van in
the market in the world where export is
going to significantly shrink they
immediately open up the financial system
to request the local banks there to lend
and that it debt created a lot of
economic activities which also resulted
in consumer demand increases and towards
the end of last year they saw that the
world economy has stabilized and the
local economy is overheated didn't
introduce quite a number of measures
administrative measures including
imposing quotas on to the local banks as
to how much you can lend and policy
matters including raising what we call
the required reserve ratio the three RS
so that the amount of money that the
banks can lend would be restricted as
well so through a combination of both
monetary policy as well as
administrative measures they are able to
quickly adjust the economy so responding
to your question I I completely agree
with whatever that has been said before
the only interesting thing is that first
of all it's very impressive I mean any
one of us who goes to China what it is
accomplished in the last 15 years is
absolutely stunning right and the social
metrics are also very good there is no
other society in the history of
humankind that has brought up so many
people from below poverty line above
poverty line compared to what China has
achieved in the last 15 years so that's
absolutely remarkable I think is always
a cautionary signal cautionary tale from
Japan for a while Japan seemed like a
company that country that seemed know
how to manage everything very well and
the government was very actively
involved and so you always worry about
so for the academics in some sense it's
a natural experiment there's a natural
experiment that's going on between India
and China China is a very strong a
resourceful government that's trying to
drive the growth in India oftentimes
people would say in spite of the
government still the country is growing
so we see Indians businessman actually
see an impediment so in some sense you
kind of look at it you know in some
sense we will know the answer in 10-15
years as to which one of the model is
actually better and I think the I think
the Chinese government is very sober and
I think they've also learnt the lessons
from the Japanese so I think the key
thing is if there are asset bubbles are
they able to deflate it slowly and
effectively and start deflating it much
before it settles on okay the last point
I want to make on that is whenever we
think about this you know it's just a
hundred twenty year history where the
other economies the European and the
Western economies have been bigger than
these two countries if you kind of go
back into 1850s and 1860s india and
china accounted for two-thirds of the
global GNP so it should not surprise us
that they could come back and regain
that status in other 20 years 30 years
so it just a big question mark is rob's
of innovative method they use that
Oh
so roll or exotic uncle Angeles let me
just say we're going to say that before
sale was positive that as the pioneer
competition advanced very well very
sensitive that's very same people right
but as Steve Sri math professor has ever
said to me Jerry the bridges fall down
no one calls for the polish with some of
your profession in fact they say over
here more better solutions so that is
what saying you work out visual sensors
Sam very is the the academic purpose of
these derivative products was to remove
volatility from the financial market and
also to render protection where direct
protection is not possible credit
default swaps were created such that if
you are investing in the particular
country and if that country faces the
political risk how do you ensure it
instant so people will come up with
credit default swap so that you lost
money in one end you get money from the
other end what had happened I think it
was stand built into what is generally
called structured products where the
original purpose of these products were
lost and then people created additional
products by leveraging the derivative
parts that was created in order to get
the return that they want after this
crisis it was known that a novel of
pitfalls have been identified first of
all as these products evolve
the understanding of these products over
over time as these products are continue
to build becomes less than this so
people are investing into these products
without truly understanding what
implications it does have secondly the I
think sometimes we say that there must
be a policeman of these things and we go
back to regulators nope do the
regulator's understand the amount of
risk that was created by these companies
to invest in these products regulators I
think have also left behind in terms of
their understanding of these products
partly because you know maybe this
process is so sophisticated and
regulators just trying to play the catch
up game but I also try to bring up
another point which may be controversial
in the way because um after the 911
incident regulators spent a lot of
effort on what is called a
counter-terrorist financing it's one
type of anti-money laundering that enter
interpreters financing and we were very
concerned that the industry is very
concerned that perhaps there were money
being channeled through the system to
move into areas which are terrorists
related so worldwide regulators be
focusing on that of those particular
areas and as a result of that the
attention that was paid to product
innovation perhaps not nobody can prove
this perhaps it has been reduced plus
the fact that the fast development of
these products was difficult for anybody
to truly understand what's what's really
happening plus the leverage plus the
breed all these things combined together
and during the initial period they do
get the return that the investors want
so investors put more money into it
the vicious cycle I just got started I
think this is what happened what we need
to do now is to again go back to the
basics what is the economic value for
the creation of this product and if it
has gone beyond if there's gone beyond
economic value then I think that's the
time where we collectively as a market
participant as the regulators as the
central banks which you try to should
try to look at but I would not say that
it was created by these innovative
products these innovative ones were
created for the purpose and those papers
continues to the event very quickly my
thought on this is I think the biggest
challenge is that the more complex the
product becomes it's becoming very hard
to actually assess the risk of this and
I think that's the became so pick at
some point in time actually I had an
accounting colleague who basically
mentioned he said that he has no idea as
to how any of the accounting firm
certifies any of the audited financial
statement because there is no way they
can understand the risk that's that
entails a lot of these things so he says
that you might think we have got audited
financials but nobody understands the
risk level of these complex products oh
if you want to be a little skeptical I
would always say one of the things and
that's going to make it really hard
regulated as well is this always the
market for sophisticated products and
this a this is an interesting article I
actually read in The Economist which is
interesting but 40 years ago 50 years
ago only the five percent of the top
class of five percent of the top of the
class actually went into finance and
investment banking right now something
like thirty to forty percent of these
people go in there and when you kind of
see the potential opportunities create
opportunities for them and then you kind
of look at India and China producing all
the smart people if they get into it
there is always a tendency to kind of
create them next sophisticated
instrument and second thing is I think
the behavioural aspects finance I think
as an area and my mind has ignored the
behavioural aspects it's humans who make
decision there's a very interesting for
those of you who is interested in
looking into that story it's too short
for me to this time periods do short for
me to describe it there's a wonderful
piece on
television on long-term capital
management and ultimately if you go back
and look into long-term capital
management the biggest mistakes were
made by people who emotionally make
decisions even though they develop the
product saying that it's people's
emotions that prevent them from
achieving higher returns so the old
product was supposed to be unemotional
but when the product doesn't work the
way it's supposed to it's humans who
just to say that now I'm going to change
that I'm going to modify that so I think
finance is an area is beginning to
understand the behavioural aspects it's
humans to make decisions the third thing
is amma is someone who looks at data to
a large extent sometimes always
skeptical whether we will ever
understand the risk until they ever
enters happen after nine eleven it seems
like so obvious somebody will take a big
plane and blow it into you know ram that
into a big building and caused the
collapse that it would seem so easy that
someone should have seen that as a very
easy way of creating chaos so we have
very few data points even though we have
got financial crisis it's very few data
points so unless you have lot of data
it's very hard to uncover the underlying
risk as well which also complicates the
problem of adding to aspirations one is
a whole area of the sea maybe this
course is a very well about this machine
this is
used in my field of water sources in a
journal so well developed but on the
other hand it's remarkable how how kind
of lose the ability to come back put
ourselves in the position of a person
may be able to see you the face of
uncertainty when they made sort of life
black squads are so obvious after you
see what they fit but imagining the last
one before one has ever shown up this
extreme yer and so this is this hose
back to you the other thing is simple
minded coming from just simple so much
genere at a financial expert the rating
agencies of this whole thing seem to
have gotten off often they seem really
drop a ball and we sit in America a
fairly only left alone people it's
surprising reference agencies should
really be used as a reference and
therefore from that perspective I don't
think we can too much blame on them
because it's up to you whether you want
to refer to them or not yeah so so the
institutions and investors themselves
you truly understand but using reference
agencies rating as a reference only yeah
as far as it got a virus hey can I can I
something add something very quickly on
that I just wanted to give a plug for
Carnegie Mellon that's one of the on the
frontiers of the behavior decision
theorists some of the smartest two
people that we know or Carnegie Mellon
and they are beginning to work much
closely with the business people in
terms of understanding the humans making
risky decisions second thing I
personally wandered kind of going back
to your rating agency issues is the
fundamental conflict of interest issue
rate it's on one hand you kind of give
the rating on the second hand you're
getting so much of business from them
this would seem like a perfect spot for
someone like Singapore to step up
because as a government deserve as a
kind of place that's known for making
careful decisions independent of all
those conflicts of interest and create a
rating agency in Singapore which does
only rating and does not do any other
business would be right I thought that
would be some kind of a model that kind
of takes it away from all the places
where this messes happen and shifting it
to some of these places would be an
interesting opportunity other questions
okay let me wrap up with one more for
you guys it's the ultimate to the
softball kind of made reference to it in
the glass diverse and that's the role of
higher education it's a softball without
us of self-interest salvage business
Singapore is no justifiable they keep
very large investments entirety three
universities very successful on the
world stage even SMU which is on the
tape
establishing some fourth University the
amounts of money government the mess of
people to send of law and come back it's
all very well known and and from abroad
it seems like it's had begin so I think
we all agree with that I guess the
question here the softball is what can
other countries who are from in India
you may reference to it before in condom
in China or elsewhere any observations
or her thoughts about this or but go
ahead the I think from an academic
perspective particularly Jerry as the
president of the University where you
have to keep faq would be happy and
retain them china has china everywhere
like everything else seem to have a very
coherent policy in this in the last few
years it has been very aggressive in
terms of building exceptional
outstanding science universities right
and it is and with its huge resources it
is allocated booze resources and it's
part or some of the best and brightest
faculty across the world and brought
them to china and they've started to do
that in business so what 57 years ago
business school faculty in china would
make but half the salary that they would
make in the US but now the top faculty
in the business book in command twenty
thirty percent higher salary in Venere
just for cost of living that's almost
like two times or two and a half times
it's a good thing that mandarin is still
not the international language yet and
so that's the tough some of the faculty
from going there I think india has its
own sort of very good universities and
actually one of the and that's what i
really like about singapore singapore
was trying to get some of you might know
the indian institute of technology is
one of the remarkably strong academic
institutions it's harder to get into
than Stan
for MIT or Harvard any of those
universities extreme even Carnegie
Mellon is extremely comparator to get
into actually Singapore was very much
interested in opening up getting IIT to
open up a campus in Singapore as much as
they like India I think one of the areas
which is kind of holding India back and
I think it there's no easy solution
there are some important social
implications because we have a long
history of different castes and having
different level of success in the
country and a democratic process you
want it to be much more representative
so I think they impose significant hard
quotas and I think that is kind of
prevented a lot of top universities from
going into India and I think if India
finds a way to and that's again place
into the strength of Singapore I think
one of the things that you looked at it
and which I always impresses me as a
person of Indian origin to come in here
that how coherently Singapore is such a
wonderful cosmopolitan place and one of
the things that always impresses me is
that if you kind of go to these areas
like serangoon or something like that
there are people who wear the kind of
dresses ethnic dresses from India that
that's even not even common the bigger
cities anymore but they will be very
comfortable in varying it in Singapore
and they can move around in Singapore on
nobody is staying at them you're not
you're not and so I think it's a
wonderful thing and I think that's
that's a hard thing father could please
replicate they need to replicate that
before they can get higher education of
the international standards yeah
professor I just have a lot of things to
add but I I think China is investing
quite a bit into the education side they
adopted the same elite system type of
education as singapore's adopting
perhaps China should do more is to open
up a bit more accepting in
differences in terms of fields as well
as solicit multiple sources of opinion
in grooming their education going
forward very good let me just in closing
observe a couple of things picking up on
these last comments I loved comments
observation not only about singapore's
commitment to higher education but also
it's wonderful diversity and tolerance I
think you're absolutely right I think
anybody from anywhere would feel
comfortable in Singapore and that's
exactly the kind of campus we've been
working to create in Pittsburgh and
everywhere else Carnegie Mellon does
business we recognize that this is
absolutely key that making progress in
the world today means being diverse
taking advantage of all the diverse
perspectives that people from different
walks of life different geographies
different backgrounds can bring to
solving a problem that's why we've
worked so hard to create the diverse
University we have and why we've
committed ourselves so much to being an
international university which is such a
key part of that diversity so in a lot
of ways Carnegie Mellon and Singapore
think alike in terms of what we try to
be in in what Singapore has succeeded in
and being we're very proud to be a
partner of so many Singapore
institutions strong collaborator with
the Singapore government and delighted
by our strong alumni base here as you
heard mentioned at the outset and I
repeated it this is our largest
gathering of alumni in Singapore we
couldn't be more pleased we're very
proud of you and we thank you very much
for your participation please join me in
thanking again professor Srinivasan and
mr.
you